hey guys how's it going so today is the
Apple iPhone se launch day and guess
what we've got one right here to unbox
so let's do it come out of here slice
they're tiny it's a good little baby
all right small tiny baby child iPhone
let's open you up very gently we will
cut here
very gently
oh my god it's so small you're so little
Ethan baby how little it's actually I
mean it is small but it's not quite as
small as I thought it was gonna be let's
do a little bit comparison of the iPhone
se to some other Apple devices the
iPhone se in comparison to the iPhone 6s
plus it is a baby
iPhone se in comparison to the iPhone 5
hmm call me crazy but the iPhone 5 the
iPhone se like it's the same exact thing
this is actually the 5s so it's minus 5s
this is the SE so I said to myself
what's the differences you're asking
here's a comparison of the iPhone se to
all the other current models that are
out right now the real difference though
is the internal part of the iPhone so
it's a quick comparison the iPhone se
has an a nine chip which is in the
iPhone 6s plus and the iPhone success it
has Apple pay 12 megapixel iSight camera
which is the same as the iPhone 6s and
the iPhone 6s plus the iPhone se also
does 4k video which the iPhone 6 doesn't
even do that it also do slo-mo video got
all of the usuals video calling audio
calling Siri and it also comes in four
different colors the Silver Gold Space
Gray and the rose gold and here's a
bunch of other super detailed specs that
if you actually care about all of that
then feel free to go to Apple's website
iPhone se comparison to the iPhone 4 so
do either the little baby let's make
some room and get that knife out of the
way because I'm going to hurt myself
iPhone se in comparison to an iPad Mini
I know Nessie in comparison to an old 8
gig
iPod what I found iPhone se in
comparison to an iPad pro it's so big
this thing is massive I'm a friend
little friend he says you want me to
take you to school I'll walk you to
school little iPhone I'll walk you to
school
in the back your lunge infant newborn
child iPhone se in comparison to a can
of your Beaumont a
so my thoughts on the iPhone se is this
is definitely not a phone for everyone
especially if you're someone who is
already upgraded to an iPhone 6s or an
iPhone 6 because most of the time going
backwards to a smaller phone it's
probably going to drive you nuts just
looking at how small this is and knowing
what I went from previously the iPhone 6
plus to a smaller phone I don't even
think that I could function on the small
of the screen for people who might not
want a bigger phone this could
potentially be the most perfect phone
for you I feel like the iPhone se is
going to be a great phone people who
have never had an iPhone who may still
have flip phones who may have old phones
or smartphones that really aren't
actually that smart sighs are live in
this tech bubble where most of my
friends are super obsessive technology
they always have the latest phones most
of the world people don't actually care
so the iPhone se I think is ideal for
someone who really just wants to make
calls send text messages take cool
photos make videos and send them to
their friends and family so really this
is not a phone for I think the super
tech obsessed people who want to have
the latest and greatest iPhone this
isn't every day phone for an everyday
normal person who just wants to sort of
do the basics and if you happen to be a
fan of smaller phones this really is the
perfect solution for you
if you still have your five your 5s and
you're so super happy with the size of
that phone here's the upgraded version
of it thank you so much for watching let
me know your thoughts about the new
iPhone se in the comments below I'll see
you soon bye
these ladies are my absolutely